barricadas alambres de púa incluso
contenedores posicionados con la ayuda
de grúas este miércoles por la mañana la
policía desplegó todos sus medios para
asegurar la capital isla babad y más
concretamente el lugar de detención de
iranran el abogado de la ex Primer
Ministro denunció una presunta detención
arbitraria
Esto no es una detención es un secuestro
estatal en segundo lugar la forma en que
se ha detenido ahí rencan es una prueba
de que la Constitución no existe en este
país
sin embargo el gobierno opina lo
contrario
se trata de una detención que no fue
motivada por la victimización política
se trata de una detención que no se hizo
por parte del gobierno es una detención
realizada por la oficina Nacional de
rendición de cuentas la institución que
se supone se ocupa de los casos de
corrupción del país en la Ford la
capital natal de ibrankan la residencia
del jefe del ejército fue saqueada así
como el cuartel general las mismas
escenas de Caos se registraron
la ciudad más poblada del país el
gobierno autorizó el despliegue del
ejército para mantener el orden público
como estrategia para contener la marea
de revueltas las autoridades
suspendieron los datos móviles en todo
pa
obligado a abandonar el poder tras una
moción de censura en abril de 2022
ha desafiado desde entonces la
legitimidad del gobierno actual y es
investigado por presunta corrupción